when I started my journey and people
started calling me the Dog Whisperer the
only thing I wanted to do is to teach
people there is no such a thing as a bad
dog
safer with me
[Applause]
today I'm still doing what I love but
the world has changed
record dog adoptions have made many
packs complete but now more than ever
people and dogs
need help we can't live like this the
problem is me what about you more pushes
more problems right he needs rehab like
ASAP so many things you can fix already
sorry for the excitement I just want you
to get bit do you know who I am together
with My Superhero pack our mission is to
Teach the World to honor the pack code
honesty integrity and loyalty once you
get this you're gonna have everything
else and that's how we create better
humans and better dogs one pack at a
time
[Music]
some cases I'm called for are true
emergencies I'm heading to meet a family
with two powerful dogs and two young
daughters when packed mates fight is bad
but a serious danger is one day the
girls can get caught in the middle as a
dog lover but more importantly as a
father I will not let that happen
[Music]
hi I'm Jonathan and this is my spouse
Sanai we've been together for six years
and we have two daughters together
Aviana she's five and then Ira she is
two years
goodness okay there
we have two dogs thano he is a
Rottweiler and he's three years old and
a Doberman Pinscher Cipher he's three
years now from the beginning we wanted
to get a dog the first one was a
Rottweiler I always loved that breed and
I just I said this is the first one we
have to get when we initially brought
down a home he was happy-go-lucky super
excited Super confident
after maybe three months we decided on
getting a second dog I had always loved
Dobermans because of a movie Doberman
Gang I saw how smart there were How
brave they were and I said to myself
when I grow up I'll have one of these
dogs that's where Cypher came in the
picture initially he was great they just
became like the best of buds in general
the way that they behave with the girls
is just beautiful I love it
once they became a little bit over a
year old the behavior started to shift
they constantly started getting in
fights
and I think we lost count of how many
times they've fought each other
when they fight it's really aggressive
it sounds like you know something
horrific is happening they fought over
human food especially in avocado they
love avocados the worst fight that they
had I was by myself with my little girls
the house
I hear a yell
and my daughter tells me Mom they're
fighting and they just started with each
other
my daughter started screaming I'm trying
to separate them they wouldn't stop I'm
yelling and seeing my two dogs that I
love so much just fighting and me never
able to stop them it was so scary
eventually I was able to push thano to
one corner and push cyber to the other
and that's when I just saw all the blood
and I was just covered in blood
after that by I I haven't been the same
I'm scared that my little girls they
were right there with me and I couldn't
keep the dog safe and I couldn't keep my
daughter safe at the same time
I I just I can't shake it off I can't
shake that feeling off it is scary to
think that my kids could end up getting
hurt because of it
it's hard to think about that
we love these dogs and we wanted to get
them when they were little so they could
grow up loving each other
what I want is just for us to enjoy each
other again despite everything we know
there's hope
I have to believe that
[Music]
foreign
wow two girls
I have two boys so I always wanted a
little girl okay so how can I help so we
have two large dogs who got in in big
fights how bad is it the worst bite was
it was a bloody mess like there was
blood everywhere yeah she was home by
herself
um and she wasn't really able to
separate them our little girl was crying
trying to go to her mom while she was
dealing with the dogs and my big sister
here wanted to grab her a back leader
yeah she just thinks so awesome
it's awesome that their older daughters
step in to protect her sister but a
child rushing into a chaotic situation
can be incredibly dangerous and even
fatal if the dogs are fighting the kids
could get caught in the crossfire we
must fix this immediately
I always like to see people walking the
dogs okay okay honestly if you don't
have to walk right you can't really
rehabilitate anything no and I mean we
can tell you that we don't yeah well go
get the dogs I'm gonna watch you from
here and I'll help you okay
this family definitely has their work
cut out for them the good thing is they
have the willingness and the little girl
I'm so proud of her she's already
protecting the sister so we got a good
pack they just need the right knowledge
let's see
okay
okay wow stop right there they're too
excited for a walk
you need to calm them down first show me
how you do it
stop
Cipher the Doberman is especially worked
out he's full of nervous excited energy
which gets Tana the Rottweiler excited
to even worse Sanaya and Jonathan don't
have the right leash or handling skills
to control the dogs and the girls are
just feet away I need to step in
immediately so can we have some halters
these leashes will give me more control
than the leashes the family is using
let's get a hold of the most excited one
this guy move a lot I need to get
control of Cypher first since his high
energy nervous excitement makes Tano
uneasy I'm gonna move back so Cipher's
aggressive energy is not right next to
Tano Cypher has an excited nervous
energy about him so this is the guy you
have to work the most oh yes see when
Cypher moves away Tano is easier to
control
I've seen how Restless I forget around
his pack made tunnel now I need to see
how he handles some neighborhood dogs I
also want Jonathan and Sinai to begin
learning how to use the leash to better
control his energy when he gets nervous
excited your dogs haven't learned to be
guided with a leash so you haven't been
able through a leash tell the brain
become calm surrender so that's what
we're gonna work on
okay I'm gonna use a short list so I
have more control over his nose and his
eyes
[Music]
bring the dogs
give a quick tuck to the leash redirect
his attention and give space from what
he is reacting to okay there you go
see he looked at me but now he's right
back into alert mode his mind is racing
let's do it again
[Music]
hey there you go
there you go
so this is a good first step even though
he's still a little Restless at least
he's sitting and coming down
when they're chilling and relaxing let's
just relax I see and he's checking with
me more now distracted by everything
walking by that's what you want it took
a few minutes but finally Cipher figured
out he needed to stay calm so now you
have to find ways where you drain the
energy this guy needs like a good run
have you done it uh okay that just said
it we've done it like once these are Big
adolescent dogs with a ton of physical
and mental energy and either cooked up
in the house most of the day that's only
gonna make cypher's nervous excited
energy worse but now the ciphers calm
down a little I want to do the same
exercise with them together so Cipher
can start to learn to stay calm and
Tano's presence
pass it to me Heather
see the second they get close again
Cipher gets worked up ciphers locked
onto Tano that's five mode no no here
hold on grab it okay
hey hey
there we're having hit
[Music]
just like before when Cypher gets close
to another dog even Tano he starts to
get aggressive that's that's what I was
going to ask you right now I feel like
he wanted to go after him that's right
okay that's correct Cipher was about to
attack Tana that's why I said you grab
that one I grabbed the guy okay his
intentions are not right yeah okay
Cipher is a worked up I don't want to do
any more work out here let's go inside I
can tell already The Cypher is nervous
excited and is instigating fights with
Tano but it's not clear what's causing
his aggression I need to find out what's
going on here if your energy is wrong
would they be affected let's say you're
mad would that affect them yeah that's
right yeah the big fight that they had
my little girls are having an avocado
and I see Dan on Cipher at each other's
faces
and then I yelled I said hey that's
right yeah and they started fighting
that is telling them to fight your
expectations that they're going to fight
is what creates the fight
I do feel that my energy just affect the
dogs we just always tend to watch the
girls watch the dogs are they okay the
baby's next to the dog there's
definitely an edge that we're at right
now your expectations are a huge part of
this but there is something else going
on here once they know that the easiest
way to drain energy is fighting they're
gonna do it okay because they don't have
anything else to do the board they're
frustrated so when a dog gets in trouble
it's because the body in the mind has
not received their daily doses of
activities yeah but they want us to
mentally be challenged yes but they
stuck here all day so they look at each
other and think we can fight just to get
rid of some energy okay yeah we're more
out of mind let's just go after each
other
yeah
freaking avocado
that's how bored they are it was clear
in the driveway that the aggression
begins with Cipher he's a doberman high
performance breed with a ton of physical
and mental energy that is often used for
police work but he scooped up in the
house most of the day with his packed
McDonald's ciphers boredom and nervous
excited energy create a combustible
situation but despite being nice the
fights comes from Sanai she anticipates
they will fight and Cipher picks up on
her fear and gets aggressive again and
again Jonathan and Sanai need to give
the dogs more physical exercise and
mental stimulation so they're not born
but completely stopping the fight will
require changes to nice expectations
around Cipher you guys have to
experience the ranch you have to come we
want to we're so excited to go to
Caesar's Ranch yeah Cypress does need
change he does need something different
so kind of realizing now that we're not
really giving him fulfillment being just
the same old thing same routine it's not
enough for him to work his mind so I'll
see you guys at the ranch you're gonna
have fun oh my God thank you thank you
thank you
the next morning Caesar heads to
Silverlake to help a pet parent who
worries her dog is too anxious to
survive their upcoming move across the
Atlantic
[Music]
Ally from Sweden I've been in Los
Angeles
25 years and stop
and these are my two clowns Ollie and
Squiggy one two always maybe Jindo pit
he's very sweet I feel like he really is
a dog who tries the best he can sit
[Laughter]
and I honestly don't know what squeaky
is I think maybe he's dachshund corgi
pit I call him East Side Special by 100
spoil them and it's probably become more
pronounced during the pandemic because I
was at home all the time I don't know
how people don't have dogs they're the
best
but right now with Ollie
there's something off
does he look like he's going to eat your
face off
[Laughter]
he is very reactive
and also very anxious he will shake
uncontrollably because he does not like
sudden noises the leaf blower is Public
Enemy Number One
I'm like are you mad are you anxious
calm down and now
um anxiety has become complete obsession
with me
Corey from Finding Nemo she's like Hi
how
he's obsessed with me at 2 and 11. I
joke that Ollie would like to crawl into
my mouth and live in my stomach
and really intense and unhealthy and
things are getting worse
and so I don't even know how to handle
it
hard to be a good boy but time is of the
essence right now because I'm planning
on moving back to Europe
decided to move closer to my family I'm
really nervous about flying with Ollie
because with his anxiety
I do have this fear that I'm setting him
up for the ultimate panic attack worst
case scenario is he has a heart attack
on the plane yeah
if I had to leave him behind it would be
so sad I mean even though he's like
cuckoo he's you know my cuckoo you need
to calm down dude
[Music]
can't just calm down
good morning good morning
how are you pleasure pleasure
I've been here in them Ollie has very
intense anxiety yet he hears a noise
there's constant barking intense shaking
he's also obsessed with me so
um a lot of work I agree
when you say obsess what do you mean he
jumped out of my dog walkers sunroof of
her car to get to me oh wow he's jumped
in eight foot fence 12 foot fence
obsessed obsessed I heard this dog was
anxious but wow a lot of dogs have
separation anxiety but I never heard of
a dog jumping out of a sunroof to get
back to his bed Mom that's not just
crazy he's dangerous let me show you the
backyard okay and we can see where they
hang out sometimes anxiety is a product
of unburned energy so I want to know how
much exercise all he's getting it's a
nice neighborhood out here did you take
your dogs on walks um I do walk around
the reservoir a lot but one of the
weirdest things that happened I was
walking Ollie just recently this woman
walked past me without a dog and Ollie
just casually turned him bitter on the
leg
is one thing for a dog's anxiety to lead
to barking at loud noises but now he
started biting humans everything about
this dog sounds more complicated than I
thought it was going to be when I first
showed up I'm feeling the suspense and
normally I don't feel suspense
I can't wait to meet your dogs
all right bring out Ollie
holy spark is chaotic this is frantic
right he's alerting but it's fire and
electricity at the same time
definitely the anxiety is pretty high
dense yeah calm down
sit
wow he does that a lot yeah
yeah yeah that's bad
that is bad
all is jumping into Maria's personal
space and she's not doing anything about
it she's not establishing boundaries so
that encourage him to get closer and
closer this is that shaking Panic so
right buddy
yes but if you give affection you end up
nurturing that he's so nervous he's
shaking that's the worst time to pet him
that's only going to nurture the anxiety
more if he's on a plane for 10 hours and
shaking like that I feel like he'd have
a heart attack but the shaking not
necessarily is bad for the heart is just
to remove energy away from you know what
I mean they don't they don't suppress
things oh anxiety alone shouldn't cause
a heart attack but a dog that's super
stressed on a long flight could
absolutely hurt himself trying to chew
or claw his way out of his crate or even
biting himself in a moment of a stream
fear it's not safe for Ali to travel
until we get this figured out but you
give an affection at that time you
actually asking them to hold it yeah
right it's best to give confidence in a
bad State Ali is a sensitive nervous
excited dog who uses Maria for Comfort
when he gets anxious the problem is
Maria nurtures the anxiety by petting
him when he's literally shaking with
fear and so he invades her intimate
space or jumps out of sunroofs to get
back to her and she allows it it's
obvious how close Marie and Ali have
grown during covet but Ali will never be
able to fly safely until Maria starts
offering calm confident leadership and
clear boundaries that he needs
okay I want you to understand that he
looks to you for guidance so you need to
tell him he doesn't need to be anxious
watch can we do the leaf blower
now instead of telling all is okay of
painting him just silently show him is
okay
hey hey
I've never seen Ollie calm down that
quickly it was pretty amazing
now the human is using the right energy
for our animal to go to come surrender
State all his anxiety around the leaf
blower is bad because Maria never shows
him he doesn't need to be anxious when I
calmly drop the leash on the dogs and
made them sit that showed them that I'm
going to protect them and they don't
need to worry this is your turn I'm
going to let you do it let's do the leaf
lower again please when Caesar says cue
the leaf blower I sort of did an
internal groan I'm just supposed to be
Caesar in that scenario
I did not have high expectations
that's good just like that
you're doing really well let's push this
a little further
City means cop make sure if you
surrender completely sit
who never sit
there you go
amazing this is learning so that's loud
noises but they have to practice calm
surrender well I would never have had a
leaf blower be able to come and knock on
my door before today
quickly the dog's settled with my
direction
I did not think it would be like that
all right this is this is come surrender
this is beautiful this is pretty good
yeah this is quite amazing for your
homework I want you to practice this
door exercise over and over you have to
become confident to achieve it just you
know make sure that that makes sense
internally yeah but there is a lot more
work to do before he's ready to fly on a
plane for 10 hours so I'll see you next
week at the DPC thank you so much thank
you thank you guys it's a lot to take in
I realize everything that I'm doing
wrong which is always fun to have
pointed out
I think Caesar has Caesar magic but
maybe I can have some of that magic
the next day Sanai Jonathan head to the
DPC with Cypher and packmate thano
to work on sinai's fearful expectations
of aggression that lead Cipher to pick
fights with thano endangering the
family's young daughters
welcome to the ranch guys
good
how's it going good good when I met you
guys it was clear we need to focus more
on the government yeah but we're still
going to keep addressing you know what I
mean we have to take him all the way to
come surrender right away I noticed how
Restless Cipher is I need to get Cypher
fully Calm before he fixates on Tano or
another animal in turns aggressive
foreign
yeah see we need to recognize Cypher
starting to get worked up and
immediately get him to sit Cipher is
more into the alert which brings the
fight
yeah this guy's always yeah that's why
we're not focusing as much on him
watch out
he's in a fight State
that's a problem
see that that's fixation
like
Cipher let's do trouble maker yeah right
this is where you need the help Cypher
was sitting calmly and the next second
he charged up my goats it's the same
thing when he fights with his back
McDonald
cyphers as smart strong dog but he's
boarding under exercise the real problem
is it's a nice constant fear that he's
about to fight which actually leads him
to fight
this exercise is going to give you just
what you need Cipher needs to burn
mental energy
okay so what we're going to do now is
going to be the tunnel you're going to
guide them through it and that will
challenge his mind more mental
stimulation will help Cipher not be
sober which is part of why he's fighting
Tano
but more importantly I want Jonathan and
Sanai to see a different side of Cipher
not an aggressive fighter but the smart
playful dog he really is the tunnel
needs two people
hold the leash that way yeah so the dog
is knowing the human just asked him to
go through
just give a little tension it's just a
little bit more
column
whatever see he's looking at everything
by you pull a little on the leash to get
his attention
yes sir that's it that's it again
every time you think something new to a
dog you're working out their mind and
for a smart dog like Cipher that's
exactly what he needs otherwise he gets
bored and that's when he fights
so your job is just with the leash guide
there we go beautiful beautiful
yeah see now he knows that you guys like
it yeah look good boy nothing this is a
huge moment not only is Cypher getting
the mental exercise he needs but now
Jonathan and specialist and I can see
that he can be playful and not
aggressive look at him
he loves it
yes
good job
what did you learn right there I had to
kind of like adjust myself everything
that I thought I knew about him I have
to just drop it out of the side start
fresh yeah I felt good right it feels
good really good yeah yeah it's an eye
opener to know it's ever could be happy
go lucky he could be this really great
dog and and I feel like I did Overlook
that a lot you have an image about him
yeah yeah exactly fighting all what you
saw right what is new for you here he's
a different dog right he's capable to be
to be there right he's this he's not
what I thought from home right we were
thinking oh whoa he's gonna act out like
this so to not let fear and just go with
our instincts your job is just to see in
your mind like who he really is now what
he became yes yeah I have a surprise for
you guys come on hey foreign
I want you to meet my chickens
and my ducks
is the chicken whisper that's it it's a
new show it's a new show I want you to
maintain what we achieve your new
understanding of Cipher and how to keep
him focused on you the goal is maintain
the level of mental focus we have back
at the tunnel once we bring back some
distractions especially important for
Sanai to be able to handle Cipher
because she's the one alone at home with
the dogs and the girls most of the time
it's also her fear that has trigger
fights so she needs to keep her
expectations positive in order to see
the behavior she wants from Cypher sit
him down
yes today I'm seeing diver as who he
really is this happy-go-lucky dog he was
not able to show to us
waiting for him to surrender that's all
I'm looking for
yes take the leash off
you see they come surrender yeah yeah I
know we have a long road for us but now
it definitely feels like this hope we
could be like this every day thank you
you saw today just how important
expectations are Jonathan and
Specialists and I have changed the way
they see Cypher and that in turn changes
the way he behaves yes this has been a
big day for all three of them but for
all this work to stick they need to
continue practicing at home
whatever it takes for those little girls
to grow up in a peaceful safe loving
environment
that's our responsibility thank you
thank you for coming thank you
foreign
[Music]
the next morning Maria heads to the DPC
with her Gino pit mix Ollie I'm excited
I don't know if you're as excited as I
am you're more anxious excited at this
stage
his anxieties are so bad he cannot join
Maria on her transatlantic move without
risking his safety
good morning and welcome so how's it
been progress not Perfection is how it's
been we started it my homework was
practicing comp at the door with the
noise like I've seen progress being made
we're definitely not at the finish line
but I'm hopeful we're gonna
get there today it's best for us to
always feed calmness who Ali really is
is a happy-go-lucky dog trapped with a
whole bunch of anxiety it sounds like
Maria has made Headway on the anxiety
around loud noises so today I want to
work on the biggest issue that will keep
Ali from flying safely his dangers need
to be close to Maria at all times so
we're gonna give him a bit of a stress
test you can wait From the Bench but
with inside of Ollie I'm gonna move him
away from you into the dog park and I
want to see how he reacts
so this is quite bad that he doesn't
even paying attention to it yeah meeting
strange new animals can provoke anxiety
in a dog like Ollie and you can see he
looks to Maria for Comfort but that's
exactly what Maria has taught him to do
by always giving him reassurance and
affection when he's anxious he's
avoiding the dogs right right he wants
to go back to the human it's like you a
little girl right and there's a whole
bunch of little kids and you don't you
don't want to interact with your own age
there's something weird about it yeah
thanks Caesar yes I'm just giving you an
example it's unhealthy attachment yeah
right so look I'm not gonna let him
avoid and focus on you
the dog should have his attention
[Music]
I'm giving more separation to get him to
detach from you yeah the anxiety and
then the attachment feed each other
I want to see if dropping the leash
helps him relax
whoa that's terrible
whoa he's seriously obsessed incredible
catch
this is why we couldn't be at the
training facility because he jumped the
fence maybe I jinxed it because I was
thinking he's gonna jump that fence and
as if On Cue he jumped the fence and
then everyone said oh that's never
happened before
really bad oh been in a strange new
place just a few feet away from Maria
made Ollie so anxious that he jumped the
fence to get back to her and that's with
Maria still in sight what is he going to
do when they're separated on a long
transatlantic flight he could buy
robotically scratch himself trying to
escape the crate the only way to fix
this is for Maria to stop being a friend
that Comforts and start being a pet
parent who gives him calm leadership and
sets boundaries the anxiety is too much
too much come on this exercise will
teach Maria and Ali both what they need
for him to be able to make a flight
safely for Maria it will show her how to
offer leadership and set spatial
boundaries and for Ali it teaches him
how to be comfortable with Maria not
being close by in stressful situations
the goal is for you to learn to trigger
calm surrender and slowly give distance
so Ollie learns to comfort himself not
to use you for that because in the crate
we want you to practice exactly what's
going to happen to him and the plane
right then we're going to play some
sounds that are likely for him to hear
it as he's in the plane yeah so that way
we begin to desensitize and acclimate
him to things that he's going to hear in
the future oh boy okay yeah
we're gonna go gradually before we work
with the crate first you're going to
make him sit calmly here on the grass
okay we're gonna do it just on the floor
and then we're going to transfer to the
crate
so first just have him sit calmly here
outside the crate
good now drop the leash
I'm gonna step back
you do it
move back
another 10 feet go back go
ah
all right let's try it again
yes
very good getting Molly to sit down in
that calm State felt like it took a
while but when I walked away I was
shocked he was still sitting there I'm
not gonna be honest but he was
yes that's it so this is exactly what I
wanted to see Maria is getting Ali to
sit calmly and then creating more and
more distance from him and Ali is
staying calm not chasing after her now
they're ready for the final step doing
the same thing inside the crate that
he'll travel in on the flight so start
by getting him to sit a little bit more
guys there we go yes
play the airplane noises
[Music]
beautiful that's it the good news is the
sounds are not going to bother him today
we completed the work that we started
with the leaf blower on day one if Maria
shows him leadership and gets him to
come surrender he's not going to be
bothered by the loud noises all in Maria
both took a big step forward today Maria
now has the tools to keep him calm but
more importantly she learned that all he
needs her leadership more than he needs
her comfort and friendship there's still
work to do but if they keep practicing
Ollie will get used to staying calm and
every situation with or without Maria
and he'll be able to travel safely on
the plane to their new home I just want
to thank you because I came into this
wondering if I was even going to be able
to get him on a plane and after this
experience I feel like we can do it oh
yeah yeah this whole process has really
reset the relationship that Ollie and I
have starting tomorrow fresh I I can
leave the house and he'll be fine
I can put him on a crate and get on a
plane and he'll be fine
I am ready
this is so cheesy you guys you guys
currently feel like a big cheese ball
come on Ollie you're ready for the
friendly Skies
[Music]
four weeks later hi Caesar get in your
crate Dolly we have been doing a lot
better thanks so much to you I feel a
lot more confident in this guy being in
a crate for nine hours and a good
bowling still planning on moving back to
Europe by the end of the year sometimes
this still takes a while to get him to
calm down but he is a much calmer more
balanced dog
Ollie's even made some friends which is
a huge achievement so thank you so much
later Caesar returns to Downey to check
on Jonathan and Sinai and their Doberman
Cipher Jonathan and Sinai must shift
their own fearful expectations which
triggers Cipher's aggression and lead to
fights with Pac made thano endangering
the couple's daughters
cypher's fighting was a condition of his
boredom cooped up in the house without
enough physical exercise and mental
stimulation but the real trigger for
this fight was sinai's constant fear
that a fight was just around the corner
I want to see if they've been giving him
more exercise and mental stimulation but
also if they have changed their own
understanding and expectations of Cipher
I'm excited to hear the news good or bad
whatever it is we've been focusing a lot
more on the exercising especially with
Cipher we have been working on him not
just exercising but mentally it's not
100 there yet but I know we got this all
right if you're feeling good let's get
started so today is the final challenge
final day before we do anything else I
want you to bring the dogs out into the
driveway like we did on the first day
right and then I'll have a final
challenge that will really put you all
to the test get the pack let me meet you
guys over here
the first time Caesar came to see us it
was a mess
Cipher just launched the dogs that were
passing
wow all right bring them out so I am
trying to make sure that
I stay calm
but I am feeling nervous
he looks like a Darwin gang look at him
totally all right so first time we met
we met here yeah it was kind of
dangerous so just to see how you guys
have improved we're gonna put some dogs
passing by just control the reaction
breathe okay let's do this bring the
first dog
okay looking good let's one more one
more
feel it through the leash
a German Shepherd just passed by you see
Remy you did great he's actually look
very calm Cipher seemed much calmer but
it's also clear that Jonathan and
specialist and I aren't bringing those
fearful expectation which is also making
Cypher calmer alright so this part is
beautiful I think we're ready for the
final challenge okay it's the moment of
truth
all right so this is where the avocado
incident happened
[Music]
yes
and that was the worst fight they ever
had right yes my little girls they were
eating an avocado he never moved his eye
away from the avocado and that's why he
becomes so like fixated fixated yeah and
this one growled right and that's when
then Donald reacted and then the fight
started right but remember the fight was
actually triggered by Sanai saying hey
her expectation and fear was the spark
this pack has come a long way but for
them to truly move forward they have to
get past Their Fear decipher is going to
act out once and for all so for the
final challenge we're going to recreate
the situation behind their biggest fight
what we're gonna do right now is to
present the avocado I'll be close by to
make sure things stay safe but the test
will be whether Sinai can stay calm and
positive and her expectations and
whether Cypher will pick up on that and
stay calm himself all right let's get
the avocado in okay
over here yeah
yeah they're comfortable
first we need them to be in calm
surrender
that's it
Cipher
get down okay I want you to put the
basket down between them and don't
forget stay calm this is all about your
energy sorry for our ears are really up
and he's focused on the Ricardo oh my
gosh
remember don't try to anticipate what's
gonna happen
now put the avocado right in front of
him
see if Cipher fixate on it okay that's
not good you don't want them to stare
because that's like fight right we want
him to pay attention to Sinai instead of
fixated in thano or the avocado
you gotta snap him out of it
Cipher good correction
[Music]
this is perfect look at the difference
see the difference in this guy now
Cipher is in total come surrender
he's doing it yes sir that's it this is
avocado success
yeah nobody ever called me for avocados
I remember in season one I dressed like
a hot dog
everybody put this away you celebrate
whatever
I'm so proud of Jonathan tonight but let
me stop before I get to mushy Caesar's
in the house
well congratulations I can feel there is
a new trust between despair parents and
Cipher and that Sanaa is bringing new
energy and expectations I am confident
that if they continue the work there
will be no issues with the dogs around
the girls how are you
yeah this is my reward you know to see
the girls happy safe peace and love the
whole family I do feel safer I feel more
in control because I know how I have to
react I know what I have to do and I
know I'm not gonna let it escalate like
that anymore
we're so grateful for our Caesar we
couldn't have done none of this without
him so
thank you
thank you for having me thank you thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys okay bye bye
I believe we can create a better planet
with our expectations if you expect to
fail you will fail if you expect that
your dog will fight they're gonna fight
but if you expect trust respect and love
that's what your dog will give you I
meet a dog that is anxious or aggressive
I picture that dog trusting and
reconnected with their instincts and by
the end
that picture in my head at the beginning
of my work
is the real thing
[Music]